75 détenus tuer en quelques heures à
peine c'est une journée effroyable
qu'ont vécu ce mardi trois prisons
surpeuplées de l'équateur l'origine de
ces violences inouïes d'après les
autorités
des rixes entre bandes rivales composée
notamment de narcotrafiquants aimons ça
me donne l aquarium
nous pouvons compter aujourd'hui sur le
soutien total de la police nationale
environ 800 policiers ont aidé à nos
programmes opala à reprendre le contrôle
et à rétablir l'ordre dans les centres
de détention entre opérations de la
liberté dans ce groupe est en dehors des
deux groupes tentent de prendre la tête
de la lutte contre la criminalité dans
les centres de détention
alinghi à valence entre filiation de la
liberté si les violences sont
récurrentes dans le système carcéral
équatorien celles ci sont
particulièrement meurtrières et à
l'extérieur c'est un sentiment de
panique qui a gagné les proches des
détenus pendant les émeutes
tout le monde sait que tous les
prisonniers ont un téléphone
nos enfants nous en dit hier soir qu'ils
étaient en danger et qu'à tout moment
une émeute allait se produire
je ne perds pas communiquer avec lui les
jolies sais rien je demande qu'il me
dise ce qu'il s'est passé
si monfils gajan mais personne ne me
donnent l'information ceux qui sont ici
à l'intérieur ne sont pas des animaux ce
sont des personnes je sais qu'ils ont
commis des délits mais ils doivent avoir
conscience que nous sommes les humains
n'ont pas de coeur ou non pas l'enfant
malgré des politiques de diminution du
nombre de prisonniers
la surpopulation carcérale atteint
toujours 30% dans les établissements
pénitentiaires
ils sont par ailleurs seulement 1500
gardien à surveiller les 30000 personnes
incarcérées dans le pays